let me tell you about my favorite
website it's it's buzz it's uh it's but
it's buzz fee it's not bad it's not a
bad website it's a YouTube channel what
it what do I know well BuzzFeed figured
it out
okay every day I think about why she
video should I make
BuzzFeed clearly figured out what the
[ __ ] to do two dollar hot dog versus
hundred and $69 hot dog
BAM seven million views thank you very
much
that will be 70 grand I'll take down one
hundred seventy-one dollars on the video
and bang you got seven grand back $100
sneaker versus $25,000 sneakers genius
now me being a greedy little Swedish
bastard you know I got some better ideas
straight off the bat $1 piss versus $200
piss $5 Pizza versus $500 Pizza but get
this there it's moldy that's hilarious
don't throw up everywhere when I eat it
$5.00 prostitute versus $200 prostitute
see I want to actually know the value
and like a $200 prostitute versus anime
pillow that's a tough one or you make
vlogs now dude those are pretty fresh
actually yeah BuzzFeed you were supposed
to be quick and snappy content Oh
someone found out about the YouTube
algorithm let's go and try some some vs.
okay see what we can come up with it's
really it's really gotten to that point
however I need to just rip off BuzzFeed
it's kind of sad isn't it anyway let's
do with it
[Music]
all right guys this pretty big deal not
everyone has this but we managed to get
from a Japanese website very exclusive
very very high quality water it costs
six six hundred eighty pounds for one
bottle its diamond water from Japan it's
been filtrated it has his own filtration
system so it filter it continuously
filters itself there's no cure of water
than Japanese diamond water like this
you know I'm pretty excited to drink
this it's pretty expensive water thank
you YouTube but I'm more excited to
drink the piss it's the thing that not
everyone can afford and I'm really I'm
really proud that they sent it to it
just cuz I'm not gonna pay for it but
600 pounds of it's pretty crazy this is
the cheap water just tap water it's
almost like drinking it can't wait to do
this we might piss okay so I'm gonna
drink this water this is the cheap water
thing then I'm gonna piss in this we're
gonna wait a day and then I'm gonna
drink this water the expensive water and
then I'm gonna piss this water back in
the bottle and then I'm gonna drink it
and then I'm gonna evaluate which piss
taste better
one dollar piss or $600 piss yeah
no real 100 right there now in dirty
bombs you'll get rid not one of these
thanks for water taste really
okay guys I finished my my first water
but I'm basically going to take a piss
right now here we go alright I got it
wow man I need to drink more water this
is not okay oh okay see you tomorrow
good night it smells really nice alright
welcome back it's time to drink the
expensive water I'm really curious what
it tastes like because bus we haven't
tried this my moonshine jar alright here
we go
I don't want to spill a drop you know
every you imagine how much a drop costs
from this alright here we go
oh my god it's amazing
I'm liking you man
oh my god my mind has been levitated
five dollar hot sauce versus five
thousand dollar hot sauce five million
dollars versus fifty million dollars a
cardboard cutout for PewDiePie Bush's
real pudding time
it tastes pure like your mama's a US the
tip of the tongue really sizzles but
will the piss taste different see you
when I need to take a piss
he's pissing he's pissing why are you
pissing you ball oh no no okay
pissin cuz he has to filter right oh it
shouldn't be too bad what are they what
a disappointing him out which one do I
start with start with this oh they all
are you serious I will stop filming this
is sanitary who isn't okay so this is
the cheapest I'm gonna drink it on that
[Music]
doesn't taste good
hey Brian you want your Christmas bonus
yeah then one miss in your face no one
miss know you don't want 50 pounds no do
you want them do you have to take the
miss my bus feed so you try this
that's that Christmas feeling you know
tastes just like Christmas so here's the
question $1 pissed versus $600 pissed I
think the result might shock you it's
beer
Wow the epic prank guys it was beer they
were like if you got pranked this was a
$600 one and I did enjoy the taste it
tasted like wasting your [ __ ] money
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]